اجتماع اخر لوضع لمسات الاخيره لحوار وطني
جديد المنظمات الوطنيه الاربعه اتحاد
الشغل وهيئه المحامين ورابطه حقوق الانسان
والمنتدى الاقتصاديه تعد العوده لانقاذ
البلاد من ازمتها كما يؤكد المشرفون عليها
مبادره الرباعي الجديد ستقوم على اساس وضع
تصور لتصحيح المسار اقتصاديا واجتماعيا
لكن ذلك يمر حتما عبر تجاوز الازمه
السياسيه الراهنه اهم حاجه
تجميع تونس على شان العام على الاصلاحات
الكبرى عشان انت مثلا
في استكمال مشروع سياسيه
في تنفيذ عمليه
في انتظار ديسمبر 2014
صور وطني او عوده الاحزاب السياسيه التي
وقع اقساؤها في 25 جنيه لا اعتقد انه ممكن
الحصول في الوقت الحاضر او في الايام
القريبه القادمه المسار السياسي الذي
ينتهي مع تركيز البرلمان الجديد انطلق معه
مسار اخر قضائيه تم من خلاله فتحه ملفات
الفساد والارهاب وتبييض الاموال
التونسي عن حجم الخلاف بين الفاعلين فيها
وبين ما يؤكد مطلقوا مبادره الحوار الوطني
ان مبادلاتهم تمثل الفرصه الاخيره لانقاذ
البلاد من ازماتها مستحذرين حوار سنه 2013
من يوليو رافضا العوده الى الوراء والحوار
مع من حكم البلاد ليله العشريه السوداء
وليد عبد الله العربيه
تونس